this is a production of Cornell
University
all right thank you Anna my name is
Marjorie hanneman as Anna said and I'm a
second year in the gore lab and my
research project that I'm focusing on
today is the analysis of vitamin B3 or
niacin in Maize grain
to give a cultural context to vitamin B3
and Maize we need to talk about next
stimulization which is a traditional
cultural practice
from Central America where the maze
kernels are cooked in lime and then
eventually ground to create a Masa to
make tortillas or tamales or other
foreign-based Foods uh one thing about
this process though is that it increases
the bioavailability of vitamin B3
and in Maize diets whether it's the
predominant food
there are uh
in cultures that don't have
nyximalization
we see severe B3 deficiency and diseases
such as balegra occur and that is
predominantly because vitamin B3 is
mostly unavailable in the Maize grain
I have this pathway here showing
nicotinic acid or niacin which is our
main form of B3
and a trigonelling is the end methyl
derivative of niacin where this compound
is inactive and undigestible because of
this methylation and in the majority of
corn kernels this is predominantly the
form of B3
vitamin B3 is also essential
specifically to the NAD cycle where
living organisms get the majority of
their energy
I have the three compounds in the
previous side listed here showing that
trigonelling is an offshoot of this uh
this cycle more of a byproduct and uh
there's some thoughts that it's involved
in a plant growth hormones but for our
cycle we're focusing on here is vitamin
B3 it is inactive and is an offshoot
from the necessary cycle
so to further look into the B3 compounds
in Maize grain we used a high throughput
lcms to phenotype these three compounds
that I had mentioned in the cycle
uh looking at about 1500 different maze
lines we can see that there were three
specifically that have extremely low
trigonelling and that would be the blue
green and red triangles uh specifically
t232 which we will focus on is a reading
line out of Tennessee
it was the same three I have an elevated
level of nicotinic acid or niacin the
active compound
and so that's suggesting that something
is happening between the nicotinic acid
and niacin step and trigonelli
also interesting though is that for
nicotinamide they're all at average
levels so we're wanting to focus on
specifically what is happening between
those two compounds
and our main question for this project
is what is genetically causing this
extremely high niacin level and low
trigonelli level in The t232 Maze grain
comparing the t232 line a B3 composition
with B104 which is a fairly standard
line that we chose because of its
ability to be transformed
you can see the difference in
trigonellian levels where it's basically
a sliver here in t232
so choosing this average line in an
extreme phenotype we crossed them and
self to make an F2 population so that we
can identify causal variants that could
be responsible for these unique rare
phenotypes
within our F2 progeny this is a
distribution of the trigonellian
phenotype and it's very interesting
because you can see that there's a three
to one ratio here
presence absence of trigonellin with
a zero absolutely no trigonelling
compared to where B104 is where it is a
continuous distribution this would
suggest that there's some sort of
genetic switch that
has a homozygous recessive allele that
is causing an absence of trigonalene and
then to have a continuous quantitative
phenotype for presence
then genotyping our F2 population with
rhmc and then inputting it into an icim
software we were doing a qtl analysis to
look at the three phenotypes we were
interested in
now we specifically wanted to look at
trigonelling where we had a very large
qtl on chromosome 4. and also seeing it
in nicotinic acid
so that would suggest that there is a
single Locus that's going to be
associated with the niacin to
trigonalene pathway
now nicotinamide also had a few qtl
Peaks but we are specifically going to
be interested in only nicotinic acid and
trigonelline for now and look into that
later since it had more average
phenotypes for our extreme lines
this qtl was also about two megabases
wide with 51 genes in it
um and then we're hoping to narrow that
down and think and identify genes that
are specifically involved in a
methylation
and specifically here is our NAD cycle
again
what is causing this to stop
so for our next steps that this project
would be to integrate our qtl results
with GEOS tus and eqtl specifically from
those 15 000 lines we originally looked
at to see if there are any genes that
would be hit here but because this is a
rare phenotype it would be interesting
to see what else is going to be
identified
additionally we'll use orthologous
information from other model plant
species such as arabidopsis to
prioritize our selection of possible
causal genes
then using de novo assembly of t232
genome we can identify the causal
variants and see if they are also
present in the other two extreme lines
and I would like to acknowledge my
committee members and specifically the
gore lab and our collaborators at
Georgia Michigan State and Iowa State
thank you
okay
um
by parental population do you develop or
that you use do you know why you use the
average line instead of another extreme
that had a higher level sure so the
question was why did we choose an
average line to make the biparental
population instead of using uh two
extreme lines that was because the
average line we chose B104 is
transformable and so then later down the
line we would be able to use that line
to use Gene editing or something else to
confirm uh causal genes I guess guys
what do you know about the background of
the line and do you have a hypothesis as
to why this is so rare
um the background of the line was It was
a
tradition a breeding line from Tennessee
um it was a non-stiff stock line all
three of the extreme lines were not the
same uh heterotic group though I am
thinking that this is a mutation in a
single Gene and that could be
uh resulting in that it continued
there's not seeing it in any other lines
could be because
there wasn't enough of a mutation to
have a selection over time
so Kelly just add mutation doesn't
appear to be lethal
but it's just occurring a very rare
variant frequency so maybe like a more
recent mutation or there's just no
selection I would say well probably a
combination of both yeah or if it did
happen
uh say 80 000 years ago through fruit
drift it could have been lost but it
probably occasionally occurs yeah
foreign
the question was if the plant otherwise
looks the same because of the extremely
low trigonalian lines uh specifically
t232 there's
um not anything obvious I want to look
more into how does if trigonaling is
going to be used as a plant hormone how
does that affect growth they're one of
the extreme lines G14 though is very
difficult to get seed from
oh I'll I'll just add this this is a
seed phenotype but we we haven't looked
at in other tissues out outside of sea
so that's on yeah
is that chickenelling an
anti-nutritional factor I mean is it is
it bad to eat outside of the fact that
it prevents you from getting vitamin B3
I guess but
um not that I know of it's just
undigestable and unprocessable it goes
through a human body
I don't know of any negative
well thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu